when bradley cooper was making this
movie uh star
is born he had to spend time with a rock
star bonafide singer someone he admired
you you got him through that i mean he
stayed with you right for a for
for quite some time and and and observed
you i guess
how does that work we just hung out for
a couple days and he just asked me a few
questions and i told him things like you
know
make sure your guitar covers your balls
at all times
you know you don't want to be one of
those guys with this well i think
sometimes the guitar
gets a little high it looks like more
like a bib
so you told bradley cover your balls so
it took a couple of
i mean he spent a couple of days in a
couple of different ways yeah and and
your big
revelation was cover your balls with the
guitar
and then if you really thought this
through
because you know then you had to kind of
like have
the talk and say look there's a few
movies out there on surfing
a few movies on rock and roll none of
them get it right
right you're putting yourself on the
line here
i don't think anyone can pull it off
it's not that you can't
if anyone could it might be you but i
just
i would really think this through and
how much time do you have he's like well
i think we start in a month i'm like oh
oh boy so so but he really did and then
and then um
there was a couple people that i had
worked with and that cameron crowe had
worked with on
roadies and um that would help with the
you know get the like the right look and
the right and
you know all right i i will admit the
first time
he asked if we would come down and see
it on the way over
i'm thinking of all the ways i can let
him down
nicely you know just like how do i not
i want to be honest right but how do i
and i it's so you know a little nervous
and i tell you when i saw it i just was
i was just [ __ ] blown away
just crazy he pulled it off it just
took me there and everything and what he
can do with his eyes
and what he you know what what they did
together
and and then sam elliott and all that i
mean it really
it took me there i'm getting i get
chills right now